[Music]  you never know when you'll find someone  who'll change your life I just didn't  expect she'd be this furry astray I was  trying to get him to fall mom she's  gonna freak out we're not gonna tell her  [Music]  what'd you break what if we named him  Michael Jordan that's the dumbest name  for a dog I've ever heard Benjamin  Franklin had a dog without Benjamin just  look kind of like you Benji he's old and  new at the same time  [Music]  Carter what is that an animatronic one I  got it you're cute but you are a dog  he's not just any dog  he's Benji you named him come with us  Frankie requesting back-up at 212 one  foot here 35 pounds more legs but not  especially  [Music]  a dog  those two they got nothing but love  Bengie he gets a new home March 16th  only on Netflix  [Music]  [Music]